you know everything's not awesome but
that's also why the lego movie 2 was the
best film of last year when the first
lego movie began production in 2011
pretty much everybody wrote it off on
premise alone I mean could there be a
more naked Lee commercial and soulless
proposition than a movie that is clearly
nothing about a hundred minute long ad
for a toy
I mean look sure plenty of films and TV
shows were developed with toys in mind I
grew up on a lot of them but they at
least had the decency to pretend to have
a purpose besides glorifying the merch
this this is just insulting
and then when lego movie premiered in
2014 pretty much everybody shut their
filthy prejudging mouths reactions were
glowing even more negative leaning
reviews freely acknowledged that the
film was better than it had any right to
be
this shouldn't have been as big a
surprise as it was since the directing
duo of Lord Miller were already rapidly
making a career out of creating good
movies a lot of bad ideas
they done it with Cloudy with a Chance
of Meatballs 21 Jump Street and the lego
movie cemented this as basically being
their filmmaking mo not only was the
lego movie good it launched a proper
franchise and its exclusion from the
best animated features nominees at the
Oscars caused legitimate outcry
now you flash-forward five years to the
fourth film in the theatrical releases
and also the first direct sequel the
lego movie to the second part
it made significantly less money than
the first movie or Lego Batman
despite a higher budget than either of
them and though well reviewed it lagged
behind both of those films critically as
well it did better than lego ninjago in
both those areas but there was a general
sense that nobody was sure what to even
make of Ninjago or how it fit with the
others outside of just using the
aesthetic between those factors and the
film being released in February it's
pretty much guaranteed that it was
left off most best of the year
considerations which is wrong because
it's amazing and I did in fact declare
it my favorite film of that year the
lego movie - isn't just a great movie I
feel superior to the original and now
I'm gonna talk about why part one the
plot let's run through the salient
points but man just in case anybody
needs a refresher the film opens with
the moment that closed out the previous
film as the toys of a younger sister
invade the lego world that represents
her big brother and it doesn't go well
so with the duplo aliens wrecking shop
and the introduction of the idea that
they take figures and bricks away for
them to never return we then jump ahead
five years and immediately we see that
the brother has entered his everything
whose gritty mature now phase as we are
introduced into apocalypse burg
everything's gritty grizzled the
characters look like they are prepping
to audition for Mad Max the musical
everybody that is except Emmett as the
embodiment of childlike wonder from the
first film it's no surprise that Emmett
stands as the sole bastion of how things
were before it all got broody a new
invader from the SISTAR's system shows
up in the form of general mayhem who
NAB's
the handful of key characters from the
first film but leaves Emmett behind
because well she doesn't take him
seriously why would you Emmett terms his
house into a ship and attempts to follow
only to face certain destruction enroute
and to be rescued by the boisterous Rex
danger vest and his crew of
velociraptors in the sistar system
Batman here in a kiddie metal beard
Benny and Lucy are introduced to Queen
whatever wannabe who uses generous gifts
to get on to the good side of everybody
except for Lucy who refuses to be taken
in there's a failed attempt to convert
Lucy through upbeat catchy music but she
resists and escapes Rex and Emmett see
the other characters who had never
returned are acting happy and joyous and
conclude that they've all been
brainwashed the pair escape when Rex
gets Emmett's channel his inner pain
into a destructive force and then they
join up with Lucy the three believe that
the upcoming wedding between Batman and
Queen whatever is a front for the
dreaded arm
mageddon and resolve to put a stop to it
the team splits up and lucy confronts
general mayhem who reveals that the
wedding is an attempt to unite the two
sides and to avert our mama gedan they
just don't know how to get the
apocalypse burg residents to pay
attention to them and their attempts
kept giving the wrong impression lucy
confirms that her friends aren't
brainwashed they're just having fun for
the first time in ages and queen
whatever is in fact the heart Emma first
offered to the duplo's Lucy tries to
stop Emmet from destroying everything
but Rex convinces him that she's
brainwashed and Emmet breaks the temple
this corresponds to the real world
brother getting fed up with his sister
and wrecking her creation their mom
arrives and declares that since the two
of them have proven they can't properly
share all the Legos then these things
need to go into storage and that is in
fact our mama gedan rex is revealed to
be Emmet from the future a future where
nobody rescued him when he tried to get
to the sistar system and he was left to
grow bitter under the dryer full of
destructive spiteful rage he builds a
time machine to go back save himself
from the asteroid field and then wreck
everything his friends were creating Rex
deposits hem it under the dryer to
ensure his own existence and then back
in reality the brother regrets what he's
done and reconstructs the heart this
revives the Queen and the rebuilding
begins
Lucy rescues Emmet Rex back to the
future's out of existence the sight of
the siblings playing well together is
enough to get the mother to reconsider
and the film wraps up that's the basics
let's start to dig a little deeper part
2 refining the concept I want to make it
clear that anything I claim to be done
better in lego movie 2 is not meant to
be taken as things having been done
poorly in lego movie 1 something can be
very good and still be improved upon
for me the major improvement from the
first film to the second one is in the
area of theming like any film there are
multiple themes worked into the
narrative but the big thumb attic core
of the
first film had to do with the way in
which a child plays versus the way an
adult plays or rather the way in which
adults refuse to let go of childish
things while simultaneously stripping
out the childlike elements and claiming
that it's totally not them being
overgrown children do you know the rules
this isn't a toy it's kind of is no
actually it's a highly sophisticated
interlocking brick system but we bought
it at the toy store we did but the way
I'm using it makes it an adult thing the
boxer this one said ages 8 to 14 that's
a suggestion they have to put that on
there the thematic elements are built up
throughout that first film has an
underlying subtext until the big reveal
moment at the end which just flat-out
makes them text the first film takes a
pretty firm stance in terms of which of
these modes of play is more valid I mean
the Lego proxy for the father figure is
the literal cackling villain of that
movie the second film also contrasts
styles of play
there's the brother who's moving into
that adolescent age where dark and
broody automatically means better while
his little sister plays in a much more
bubbly manner not a million miles away
from how he used to play in the previous
film without also being a straight up
mirror image it's worth noting but this
film is much less judgmental about the
styles of play themselves than the first
one was we don't have as clear-cut a
case of one being inherently better than
the other and it's not like the brother
has become what his father was in the
first film which is good because we're
not doing becoming what you wants fought
against here since we're dealing with a
smaller age gap between the two styles
of play the differences are a bit more
nuanced and since the cat's already out
of the bag in terms of what's really
going on the ways in which what we see
parallels the real world gets to be very
clear from the outset that's how we get
awesome moments like this
nor did noise
because who hasn't been trying to play
with somebody younger and been immensely
frustrated that they weren't following
the rules or had somebody literally run
away with your stuff under the guise of
sharing but it's not just a different in
age driving things this time Lord and
Miller as the writers along with
director Mike Mitchell also play with
the expectations and some of the
realities of how boys play versus how
girls play now initially on first
viewing I felt disappointed at the
handling of this I thought there'd be
more commentary on female versus male
centric toy marking and I felt like they
didn't do all that much with that
dichotomy but in reality they actually
do quite a bit with it I just didn't
take proper notice of it on first
viewing because I'd expected the themes
to be as upfront and clearly laid out as
they were in the first film and their
approach to gender dynamic it is there
but the nuances of it kind of scooted
under the radar for me initially this
film uses preferred modes of play as a
microcosm for the players personality
much like the original but now it also
gets to work with how changes in play
reflect changes in self through the
brother character because we have the
first movie to compare to in addition to
the arc that he has in this one and the
commentary on a more for lack of a
better word girly style of play is
absolutely present it just doesn't take
the form I expected it to because rather
than going the easy route and saying the
whole pink aisle for girls thing is so
dumb or really even passing much
judgment on how the sister plays it all
the film instead turns its gaze on to
how the brother responds to that kind of
play invading his current play
preference why does this matter well
part three beaming is Kenny
so the film does tackle feminine versus
masculine play styles just as I said
with more subtlety than I had been
looking for on that first viewing and
honestly tackling the way that boys and
girls tend to play differently at all
was a bit of a land mind of an area to
even try and address because it risks
dipping into reductive stereotyping of
what boys and girls are supposed to be
like the film dodges this issue pretty
nimbly primarily by never drawing
excessive attention to the fact that
that's what it's doing signposting it as
plainly as the first film did with its
theme might well have ruined the whole
thing so if nothing else you've got to
admire the restraint now I suspect some
of you might be thinking okay so it's
not as blatant as blue versus pink but
isn't it all still rooted in the overly
broad and possibly arbitrary distinction
between supposedly masculine and
feminine play and yeah it pretty much is
and that's worth making a mental note of
however I'd caution anybody who goes
down the path of it's all still
arbitrary so we should just forget it
and move on because to try and brush
past how boys and girls are perceived to
play differently is to fail and examine
the ways in which these distinctions
arbitrary or not have shaped the way we
view and relate to each other it's like
when you're talking to a friend and they
bring up something from a while ago that
maybe you're a little embarrassed by you
know I was shamed of your part in it and
go look that was a long time ago we
don't need to talk about it let's just
move on sounds good have a savior ego a
little bit but if you can't have a
certain healthy conversation about it
then you may not in fact have properly
process it and instead just opted out
pretending it didn't happen and the
things lego movie 2 has to say about
masculine and feminine play are
admittedly fairly broad but that's
because the way boys and girls have been
expected to play and have been marketed
towards including by the Lego company is
also pretty broad and the
isn't making absolute statements that
all girls do X and all boys do Y rather
it's a reflection of the fact that boys
are encouraged through entertainment and
marketing aimed at them to play
destructively and girls are encouraged
to play more docile e and homogeneously
basically to play house think about the
toys and the games marketed to boys toy
guns monsters action figures with good
guys and bad guys who come with weapons
and vehicles to do battle with each
other girls can certainly play this way
too but the marketing for these toys is
clearly targeted at boys flipping that
around girl toys are meant to be friends
with each other they have pets to play
with in homes to live in their pristine
and pretty with braids able hair and
changeable outfits action figures come
with weapons dolls come with a hairbrush
what do you feel this is how it should
be or that it's stupid and arbitrary
which yeah pretty much is at the very
least yeah I need you to go with me when
I say that's how things have been for a
while for us as a culture and that
culture and the marketing does impact
the way many children choose to play now
the film is shown primarily through the
lens of the brother so we're seeing
things first and foremost from the
perspective of masculine play and
through that lens the feminine side is
immediately distrusted Queen whatever is
just giving them stuff trying to be
friends that is super suspicious the
heroes who never came back are happy and
dancing and getting along that's just
not right the music's peppy and upbeat
oh hell no it's a genuinely brilliant
realization that all of this was
actually sincere none of it was a trick
none of it was sinister it was just how
the sister plays but through the eyes of
how boys play all of it was
automatically wrong while all the
niceness of the sisters choice was
honest it was the more boyish elements
that were the affectation embodied by
the character of jam
mayhem because as the sisters avatars
they put on a helmet and kick butt
because they thought it was the only way
to get the brothers avatars to play with
them interestingly the movies are really
judging the brothers mode of play to be
a bad thing in and of itself at least I
don't think it is yeah it's making fun
of the brooding moody nature of it but
it did the same with how nonsensical
things were with things like cloud
cuckoo-land in the first film where the
film does pass judgement is how playing
in this mode colors and shapes the
brothers ability to even accept other
ways of playing or see his sibling as
anything other than an intruder because
getting locked into this mode of play
has him thinking primarily in combat
terms that makes this whole thing an
invasion to be repelled a scheme to be
thwarted a fight to be won the sister is
trying to meet him halfway
as best she can without giving up what
she likes but he'd sooner destroy all of
it then give in to a style of play world
wedding is the ultimate goal we also
have parallel theming taking place as
Lucy spends a chunk of the opening
trying to get Emmet to drop his bubbly
nature only to see him swing too far in
the other direction and not listen when
she tries to stop him from destroying
everything this might sound like it's
not all that comparable but the core
struggle in both this and the masculine
versus feminine play conflict is
centered on an inability to accept
something as it is and trying to force
change and what's fun about Lucy and
Emmett's track is they actually flip
roles halfway through initially it's
Lucy trying to make Emmet be different
even though this is clearly just who he
is but when Lucy realizes there's
nothing wrong with the other way of
being it's now Emmet who refuses to
divert from the path he's on the path he
started to be on in order to please her
and he just tries to bash everything
into the shape that he wants it this
reversal is a great touch
avoid assigning blame exclusively to
either the male or female main character
and in a movie with gender dynamics on
its mind that is a really good way to
balance the whole thing and Lucy's need
to accept her own past which is a
history of being a much peppier
plaything also fits comfortably into
this little theming cluster because
there's something that the brother needs
to recognize about himself because as I
noted before his sister is not playing
all that differently from how he did in
the first film and his losing sight of
that losing sight of that connection is
part of why things get as destructive as
they do at the climax now it should be
said there is a joy to be had in
destructive play which the filming self
acknowledges by having Emmett's first
use of master braking be so cathartic
but it's when the lens of destructive
play begins to intrude on how someone
interacts with the world at large that
things can go off the rails and the way
the sister plays doesn't go completely
uncritical placate her brother by making
general mayhem into something she's not
can be read as reflecting a conciliatory
mindset reflective of how girls are
encouraged to behave in more docile ways
more docile modes of play all of this is
way more intelligence and nuanced a
critique of the masculine versus
feminine play modes that marketing has
hammered into us over the decades that I
expected from this film which is why I
missed it the first time even though my
dumb ass didn't catch this stuff on the
first go I still singled out the key to
the whole thing part for the heart of
the movie
one of the most memorable things about
the first film was the oft-repeated song
everything is awesome
[Music]
it was catchy it actually served dual
roles in the film Lord business used it
to placate the populace into believing
that everything was fine and not
questioning the world as he laid it out
for them
but Emmet's unabashedly of the song
means that at face value the celebration
enjoyed to be found in everything that
you're willing to see it is also given
validation it's pretty clever all things
told though it does actually muddy the
themeing a little bit in that first film
because it's not like Emmet reclaims the
song and gives it new meaning he had
just actually totally bought into Lord
business's whole shtick and he retained
the love of the song even as he breaks
out with a mindset that it was meant to
enforce and that doesn't really get
addressed I'm not sure the first of all
had an obligation to address that but I
think it might be part of the reason
that I saw a bit of a minor backlash to
the film specifically around that song
and that backlash came from people who
seemed to think the film was literally
pushing the idea that everything is
awesome as its core message and those
people scoffed at it like their syndrome
from The Incredibles
and with everyone super no one will be
it would have been easy for the sequel
to just ignore all that on the basis of
people not paying proper attention but
lego movie - instead combats this
perception head-on firstly the film is a
full-on musical something even
acknowledged in universe oh no are we in
a musical yeah get ready so since it's
no longer just one song repeated over
and over and over again it becomes less
likely that anybody is going to come
away putting a disproportionate amount
of thematic meaning on the shoulders of
a single song the way some people did
the last time around it helps that the
songs in lego movie - are pretty good in
and out of themselves Queen whatever
gets two really fun numbers not evil is
easily one of the best character
introduction songs since you're welcome
from Moana and Gotham City guys help
speed up the temptation of Batman scene
smoothly while also allowing for a few
fun jabs at the character because
seriously this franchise gets Batman
better than most of the people who've
made quote-unquote real Batman movies
and of course there's catchy song which
serves as a joke on youth targeted pop
songs in general and even a bit of a jab
at everything is awesome in particular
but what I really want to focus on is
the fact that the true heart and soul of
the film comes in the form of a song
because the thing the characters were
dreading our mama gettin happens the
toys get banished into storage and the
film was a proper fake out by pretending
that's the end and then as Emmett has to
face the fact that he's the villain and
has doomed everyone and all the others
are facing eternal confinement we get
this
no it's over singing about it that
doesn't mean that it's hopeless in
Bleach everything's not awesome
but in my heart I believe
to make things
[Music]
we stick to
[Music]
to get
[Music]
this song is not only the perfect point
to turn the film on but it is a wake-up
call to all the naysayers from last time
because if you really thought the point
of the first movie was that literally
everything is awesome
then you were not paying attention and
this is for you no it's not all awesome
but we have the power to make it better
maybe not truly awesome but better than
it is right now and the fact that it can
never be perfect is not a reason to not
try and if you're wondering yes this
does factor into the themes we've been
talking about because everything comes
to a head when the brother and the
sister though mostly the brother try and
make everything be their version of
Awesome and it just all blows up because
it can't be exactly what either of them
wants it can't be perfect but rather
than give up and sending everything into
storage the song marks the brothers
realization that fighting each other to
have their own perfection got them both
nothing but building together can still
get them something worth having part 5
the weird solution at the end so let's
come back to the resolution of Emmet
story because I've seen a few people
take issues with it not massive issues
not throwing the toys out of the crib
tantrums but I've seen it come up
specifically it tends to be the
time-travel mechanic and how in the heck
does that even work in this world given
that reality analog and and everything
else going on virtually everything we
see in both the previous film and this
one has a direct real-world explanation
the kragle is crazy glue Lord business
wanted to freeze everything is the dad
being over controlling heroes being
captured by this is just it's the sister
borrowing toys and then never bringing
them back the destruction of the wedding
table is the brother throwing a fit our
mama gedan is the mother packing
everything away but
what in the heck is up with a freaking
time travel I mean we see that Emmet
legitimately gets left under the dryer
so something has to have truly changed
real-world history not just the Lego
world how does that even work and the
answer is simple
doesn't matter how it works because it's
not there to fit perfectly as a piece of
a puzzle it's not there to pay off floor
building it's not there to stand in for
anything tangibly real its thematic I've
got a bit of a reputation as a nitpicker
a reputation enforced quite regularly by
me I mean I have a series on this
channel called nitpick rants for crying
out loud you'd think that something like
this would drive me nuts because it
appears to break the established rules
of this world as we understand it but I
think it's perfect now I don't get to
talk about this very often because it
just doesn't happen nearly as often as
I'd like but I do make allowances for
rule breaking and bending the logistics
if it has ample thematic justification
to pull an example in the original
matrix after being gunned down by Agent
Smith and dying in both V virtual and
real worlds neo comes back to life when
Trinity kisses him and this does not
really gel with any established internal
logic of a film there's a token
recursing hand wave explanation about
the Oracle telling Trinity she's
destined to fall in love with the one
and she loves neo so he must be the one
but that is pretty tanked then
especially given that this is the same
Oracle who told neo flat out that he
isn't the one and she's been framed as
telling people what they need to hear
even if it isn't true
so who knows how literally to take any
of the prophecy stuff but it doesn't
matter because the reason neo comes back
to life is because his journey has been
one of acceptance of himself of his
place in the world of the reality he's
only just discovered and Trinity's
Express
of love is a literalization of
everything that he has had to accept
also accepting and embracing and loving
him in return and that is why he comes
back because it makes 100 percent
thematic sense it so it doesn't have to
make a hundred percent logistical sense
and we're gonna see the exact same thing
with the time travel in like a movie -
because within the reality of the film
there is no internal mechanism that can
truly justify time travel and rewriting
history but the desire the need to go
back and fix a mistake is the thematic
core of the brothers realization about
how badly he screwed up by letting his
anger get the better of him in his rush
to grow up he created something so
destructive that the only thing to do is
to rewind the whole thing and undo
what's happened
heck the film itself Clues you in on
this entire trick by invoking the one
bit of the original film that didn't
really make sense then but was
thematically relevant you know what I
mean
who was the bit where Emmet moved on his
own which in the first film also made
more thematic sense than logical sense
it's almost kind of annoying how clever
the people behind these movies are part
six
everything fits together so as I've
gotten older I've come to appreciate
deep and expansive theming but I can
still be critical of when too much of a
story or characters get sacrificed in
the name of it theming especially
tightly integrated theming can make a
good story great but it can't save a bad
story it can only make a bad story
pretentious I group themes together with
narrative metaphors and allegories as
something that works best when the story
is still coherent and worth telling even
if those things weren't there
films like mother tree of life even
sucker punch they don't flow or make
much sense if you don't catch the themes
and allegories running through them
they're more themed than they are plot
and I'm not saying that that's an
invalid way to create art honestly
experimenting is vital to the life
any creative medium but that pretty much
never works for me if it's not a story I
care about when told straight I'm not
sticking around just because it's got
themes but films like into the
spider-verse annihilation Zootopia the
grey Beauty and the Beast the real
version Blade Runner and yes lego movie
to the second part are telling stories
that I'm on board to watch in and out
themselves and then proceeded to
brighten and polish nearly every element
through tight consistent and expansively
integrated theming which boosts
virtually everything about the film
without announcing their presence on a
megaphone lego movie 2 is moving many
folks seem to have let fade from their
memories but I am here to tell you that
if you thought it was light and
disposable and just cashing in on the
popularity of the first one you owe it
another chance with an eye on everything
going on that you may have missed the
first time around and in the meantime
just remember the wise words of unikitty
[Music]
thank you for watching if you like this
video I hope you'll consider all the
usual stuff like subscribing commenting
thumbs up I also have a patreon if
you're the generous type but you also
don't have to do any of that because in
the end you're the council
I'm just round the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]